[Applause]
in in where northern styles welcome back
[ __ ] well done yes yes back out there
are some very discerning demanding
clients yeah
customers that are expecting the best of
the best
yeah bloody good to have you back yes
let's get going yeah right
time for the starter yes king crab
tortellini yes ready yes yeah
first Susan yeah we're to kill the crab
yeah don't turn your noise above that
yeah of course
yeah take the crab for God's sake woman
let's go right on here please
excuse me if you do cook it you're gonna
have to kill it first Susan you're
acting like a soft southern Jesse come
on stop [ __ ] around in that tree
there knife from there very carefully
and bang straight through and then we
crunch fro through there okay gotta kill
it quickly okay say goodbye to him first
quick certainly good good girl right
excellent
now we're going to take off the cluster
it's true yes there's one cluster hold
it please
hold it there you go and there's your
second cluster in the water nice bring
it back to the wall
cook it first table yes four covers
table 2 for 12 any for lamb for
chocolate souffle yes right let's get
all the tortillas yes then we serve two
totally nice proportion yes
two thirds of a spoon and we just take
wash half for tortellini she was glad to
do that
Spanky's tip that's right up into your
hands push and nipple the air out you
ladies got discipline fingers you can do
that yes okay right let's just quickly
go through the source together yeah
lemongrass olive oil yes it's like a
sort of tomato olive oil sauce yes she
locks in there we've got our basil
coriander tomatoes in and just leave
that cooking away but we use this coat
one and a half minutes
gently boiling water right sauce out sir
pastures cooked and then from there onto
the plate
king crab to blini we're a fresh tomato
and lemon grass vinaigrette
yeah those yeah would you pay for them
yes double ten there JB please yes she's
Hollywood installed
saundra apparently upset your mum last
time you're on the air for it yes by
swearing is that right yes chef I had a
pep talk before we let this mind in me
and Susan it was about to our coaches at
dawn
Ariel ever saw is not good at about my
moment there with it after mine will the
follow-up program yeah serious why not
always get the play I don't mean to
swell yeah
the company I mean ladies it's [ __ ]
great to have you back
that's nice it's good table 9 here very
nice
hey Susan you in charge the hot plate
while I'm gone for 30 seconds ok very
nice and tidy
hello Johnny how are you nice to see ya
yeah so good to see ya know it's so good
to be Emmett later we'll hit the head on
the recipe challenge and have you
concede chances I've really found some
assurances I figured something that's
beyond you I think you've developed
beyond simple good phone service let me
just show you we're gonna be cooking
another quick look at the kitchen
I'll show give you a head start so you
don't so no ladies will you get in there
hey I don't bring you to just work the
room these ladies are also from
Lancashire ladies please Johnny yes yes
tumbler and Justine right right Vegas
get Tony Vegas out of this kitchen
outlay Jeff bloody how
[Music]
like made you the shaggy sheep farmer
doesn't like to waste anything
I just slaughtered my sheep kind of
invited to play the wizard stall round
40 yeah yeah extraordinaire day is here
to help me cook up a family feast with
some of the more unusual cuts the most
amazing brains and the breads Wow
they are extraordinary a little while
since I've cooked sheeps brains really
so you've got two different types of
sweetbreads are strung the long thin one
obviously being the throat glands yep
and there's at heart
yeah look um they're beautiful huh huh
very tender she's really weird haven't
taken them out myself this is certainly
be the freshest set of brains I've ever
worked ready now do you think Tyler and
the kids will eat sweetbreads and brain
tunnel definitely jack we'll definitely
the girls I'm not too sure you know that
good to have your garden back it will be
yeah well it's um done but I don't know
it's really weird with it now as you
start to miss them isn't it where's
Gavin oh he's up in the oxygen
roaming around on having some fun
has he still got his knuckles yes so he
can be a breeding ramp I think he's
going to have a retirement what an
extraordinary turn of fortunes for him I
know I'm just gonna quickly set off
these but you're way ahead of me now
onions no don't worry you can take one
job again
I'm Caroline my onions in Muscovado
sugar gives a really nice dark rich semi
spice and then just gonna put some
balsamic vinegar in there I'm just sort
of caramelize them almost like an onion
marmalade
I don't put mine in slowly and a color
and slowly get nice and crispy and then
they'll take 810 minutes to cook okay
likely folks a little popping in now
all I'm going to do is saute the veg
poach the brains and add so to the
brains and put the two together nice
leave the cooldown [ __ ] my garlic first
slice the sweetbreads up now they've
cooled down just set nicely these brains
nice like poaching an egg how lucky are
the kids five lamb brains and
caramelized
sweetbreads with a marmalade of onion
capers and vinegar I was gonna do just
the lightest sprinkling of cider vinegar
already on the brains themselves being
pretty right sit down
two very exciting dishes thank you yours
is its brains with babies mmm this its
throat glands and sweetbreads
I prefer the brains of you eat brains
again sweetbreads again a pond and get
yourself a couple of crocodiles
not it was lovely I thought it was
presented very nicely and so many
flavors coming through I really enjoyed
it
why me in these things with legs and
shells I'm sure it was happier in the
thing that its flesh was already in and
with this it can't even walk sideways I
feel like I've insulted the chef who is
the chair okay right ladies come over
please result yes starters yes well
they're happy very happy
yeah right give me we go thank you okay
no matter customers they're happy to pay
for their toppling of king crab out of
fifty forty six too much pasta and
nothing off crab next to my menu
the Lancashire lassies go commando and
my very special shepherd's pie proves a
problem for Ricky Gervais where's it
gonna end
me on Jeremy Clarkson in a helicopter
shooting your cousin so tasted
[Applause]
welcome back to the F word time for the
main course my lambs now I'm doing two
ways first up leg of lamb
[Music]
leg of lamb the king of all joints sweet
tender very rich absolutely delicious
I must have for every dining table get
your butcher to bone it out and
butterfly it basically so you can tie it
and roast it
[Music]
hot oven season
Olive Oyl
[Music]
means use it in abundance it's fresh
it's fragrant smells amazing
goat cheese the mints perfumes the
inside of the lamp and the goat cheese
just sort of makes the center nice and
creamy garlic
roll
[Music]
first of all a big loop around the lamb
that needs all these shape get a nice
length of string tie a knot right the
very top underneath and leave it coming
out here the secret I knit this shape
helps to cook it evenly and look
beautiful rosemary
[Music]
season gets the skin really nice and
crispy olive oil stops the string from
burning so therefore it won't burst open
when it's in the oven
bingo rose 35 minutes
Cobb
you make vinaigrettes
[Applause]
[Music]
that has confirmed it's definitely the
king of grouse roast leg of lamb with
doechigi that meant done lamb nicely
seasoned how long does this go in the
other part pink 35 to 40 minutes in yeah
special lamb as you know there's gonna
be rested for literally the same time as
is cooked toes nice and pink if you keep
warm while its resting all that time
absolute definitely I doubt so it's
really important now to get some color
on the lamb
yes okay okay yes
tonight I'm seven lamb two ways you've
seen the leg and this is the nation's
favorite ship with pie a great British
classic absolutely delicious mince
vegetables potatoes easy
Olive Oyl
minced lamb still the color on the mince
and it gets rid of that unwanted fat
nothing worse than a greasy shepherd's
pie season
onion
garlic once the vegetables are grated in
there they could centigrade and almost
puree adding great flavor and that's the
secret behind a really good shepherd's
pie it's all in the mince what's the
sauce tomato puree
red wine
time rosemarie right now the red wines
evaporated chicken stock in
I cook out for three or four minutes no
more than that
[Music]
potatoes
mash season
egg yolks now
secret ingredient commas and cheese
we've got generous for the parmesan
because that's what gets it really nice
and golden brown now deserve to sit on
top of my mints
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good old-fashioned tip just give my mom
happy
at the top 18 to 20 minutes in the
[Applause]
[Music]
the crispy topping you can see what that
deserves to be a great British classic
shepherd's pie done 46 out of 50 of the
starter try and get 50 out of 50 for the
lamb yes yep
tonight yeah it's all about perfection
yeah let's do it out of respect for my
lambs yes Judith and Susan five portions
away please yes let's go carrots take
out and leave on the top there yes okay
let's go ladies yeah yes yeah we put the
lamb on there keep the round bit up to
the top nice right nice not too oily
please ladies you service please
yeah Table six please yes
ladies and get bring nervous you very
quite what's the matter in chat torment
it command no indication I was 21 years
of age for God's sake I don't come on
though anymore now it's time for tribe I
forgot some food that I personally want
to put back on the menu I see how it may
look disgusting but I love a bit of
tribe now it's very cheap very
nutritious but sadly these days you've
got to go through a hell of oil ship to
get hold of it tripe is the lining of a
cow's stomach
they have been voted Britain's and least
favourite food which i think is a waste
in my grandparents day everyone a tribe
and I'm determined to put it back on the
map love tripe I grew up with tripe it's
been in the family for years and having
lived in France and Italy that's all we
used to eat for staff lunch was tribe
I've managed to get my hands on some
fresh cows guts
I'm bought into a tripe dresser before I
can cook with them Peter how are you
likewise good to see you too my man now
it's down to you to turn into something
some magical in 1900 there were 200
tribe presses in Britain your
great-great grandfather look now they're
only three and the smell I mean this
place just stinks of tribe what does the
wife's at home she doesn't she doesn't
she left she's that Peter and I boil my
tribe to make it more tender and then
bleach it to improve the color
it's hard to believe that's the same
tribe you know in terms of you know how
palatable it looks now
Peter supplies Bob and Christine run a
traditional tribe store at the market in
Akron and Stanley their customers love
tribes so much here they even eat it raw
it's all very easy cold nice on the
green to find out who's actually buying
Bob's tribe I'm gonna give him a hand on
the store thank you
oh that's nice and cozy please 91 on
Saturday many happy returns morning sir
who are you gonna have this morning
jelly onion is that for tonight's dinner
no no actually that's that's just for
snack the fact that just been here for
the last five minutes and watching you
know the customers coming and pick up
the tripe how old they are and in a way
that you know there's not enough use
eating it ladies there's anyone out
there on the age of 30 who would like to
buy some tribe tribes clearly got an
image problem and many young people
haven't even tried it
so with Bob's help I'm setting on very
own belly deli to reinvent it as a
really tasty dish dongs gut huts
right and Bob what we got to do is
something sort of modern okay that's a
pan fried tripe yes with some lemon and
parsley if we get it looking fresh and
modern a lot more people than who eat it
okay first of all chop some onions and
garlic and sweat so this is a my way of
doing tribe sort of fast
yeah like fast food then toss the tribe
in some flour and season with salt and
cayenne pepper well just to make it a
little bit more sort of tangy and fresh
you use vinegar don't you yeah I'm gonna
grate some lemon on there yeah and what
that does it just makes it a little bit
sort of lighter fresher and a little bit
more zestier yeah
I don't wanna do now is fry it very very
quickly
okay seasoned with fresh parsley and a
squeeze of lemon yeah yeah now we're
ready who would like some trolley please
anybody here in Akron that hasn't eaten
tribe yes where are all the tripe
virgins you why haven't you had tried
before my darling you like it actually
yes and it's quite in a planet well I
think about right yeah good girl Hey
look these new customers you're getting
you liked it so we've gone from 90 to 18
this morning right guys come on how are
you doing now this is accurate and
Stanley's 100 Evans this dish here is
full of protein holding six tonight the
time yes fantastic it's a load of
bollocks that people don't like type
anymore because cooked in a modern way
they love it
look at this lot next time you're out
get down to your butcher and get some
try for dinner it's delicious and
healthy
now know you don't like fancy foods
enjoy the super spy absolutely wonderful
I mean shepherd's pie would be in them I
think my top five really ought to say
that and and that was that was lovely
the mints for the ships by was from the
Lambs that had a my back garden so hold
on so they were basically your pants
weren't pets fall into that habit of
allowing to become pets although they
are very friendly to begin with but then
you go sort of distance yourself on them
yeah but you say that always it gonna
end you and Jeremy Clarkson in a
helicopter shooting your cousin I get
distance from them and they're so tasty
I'm glad you share the menopausal women
carrying a stab who do you think you are
no but you enjoyed it didn't you I did
enjoy it obviously I'd rather know that
that animal had a wonderful life
absolute killed you mainly Gavin escaped
that's given your name I know how I know
I mean what why would you do that what
we see when you when you buy in Tesco's
there's not unknown okay Bob Bob Gavin
didn't die Charlotte unfortunate got
eaten what am I about we want a
suspected Puma a wild cat or a humungous
farm where do you live he was humongous
[ __ ] it snow is it serious who doesn't
cook in at home I do it's not I don't
ever know let me tell you why bored
please I'm a genius
I've got to save all those skills
further things okay I thought seeking
merger was a genius now you're not just
brilliant and making people laugh
you also bloody fantastic make your
money and the DVDs the podcast animals
have you ever been tempted or swayed by
doing an advert
no I'm not tempted you know I got
offered a million pounds to do a Juniper
when the office Pope in America and my
ages I know then to adverts but I just
run this by you and I went nah cuz I
just thought if I said the Exide regret
so I said no and he said they've come
back with two million they thought I was
haggling oh my god and I think it's
because you haven't had the right
product ok so I've got some items that
will you to have a look at and tell me
how you would market them in an advert
okay first thing go on block chocolate
bar it's a delicacy in Sweden and how
long foreign and how much effort I said
how would you sit there and lunch and
it's a Swedish I prefer it would be a
really weird one wouldn't it it would be
to like Oh there'll be several out
wouldn't it what about one at that
that sexy rabbit used to advertise
Chopra's caramel no yeah yes not really
sexy rabbit can we cut that I've never
had sex
anyroad it's a lagom okay this one you
like soup don't you yeah yeah okay so
it's a [ __ ] flavoured Buddha flavour
excellent Oh God slurp it out the Great
Basin car okay finally to wash it all
down it's closer to Sweden is this would
be Ming's beer vodka I'm slightly
squeamish to drinks Oh God now the throw
in that that's very old spunk
that's that smoke that's been hanging
around for quite some time
how do you promote and the Danish shot
of spunk vodka
that's the best fun they'll ever tasted
really good to see ya wonders for the
good work thank you very much see my
done because I'm gonna see have all the
lower section really nicely cooked
very tender and I like the lemon zest on
the top but was delicious the lamb but
terrible shame out the goats cheese in
the middle of it but once it squeaked is
now tasted nice and tender it was the
same there's another knee stress I'm at
the good life right results this is
quite special for me yeah it's a lot of
hard work months getting that ready yet
in terms of looking out from nursing
them and doing all we can to improve
that flavor yes Jamie right I thought
you did a bloody good job yeah clearly
the most talented reggae we've had on so
far however yeah they are the critics
they're your customers and the amount of
customers are happy to pay for the main
course
down
48 hours 50 is not quite perfect yes
there's brief improvement JP just said
we just why didn't you pay who was that
too much meat and too much tomato my
next on the menu I let my Fanny loose in
the kitchen out of my kitchen but
plainly after you've done the washing up
and 18 stone of idiot takes me on in the
recipe challenge I have Gordon Ramsay
parties we all just sit around telling
show that [ __ ] up
[Applause]
welcome back the f-word now tomography
to take on 18 stone of idiots John are
you ready yeah no what are you cooking
I'm cooking pizza pizza yeah
very simple very rustic food to the
peasants speaking working-class into
these kitchens and giving them a taste
to sub this subs done something real
something that we can just drive past on
a Saturday night and watch people eating
got how do those people live perfect now
what's that secret machine what is that
they seize my blood lake stroke door
maker because I don't think that I do
that I am I'm just doing a very simple
Peter fresh tomato sauce and then top of
some really nice Bayonne ham just put me
forward in which is a very decent double
zero Italian flour what will I do now is
that the olive oil but I've got a
tablespoon measure abuts all right I'm
going to do it by eye because a guy I am
I've got me live yeast here because I
don't like the giant pile good stuff and
you never get the right result with it
starts it next you're not actually
making your own pizza dough you're
putting it together machines making it
for you no it's not my shootings [ __ ]
for me bollocks cheating [ __ ] I don't
work for you I can't speak to me like
this Johnny be good I am being good
water at the boil put my yeast in
machine it's the worst at the devil
whisk in the yeast activates it touch of
olive all in there touch the salt
absolutely crucial from there flour into
the normal food processor so what you're
using no garden is that machine this is
this machine is a machine it's a great
ballgame hey smarty pants what you're
doing the tartar sauce it's not sauce is
just it's just me tomatoes salt yeah
tiny bit of sugar oregano and some fresh
basil
so Johnny's making a very simple tomato
sauce out of tin tomorrow Saab has got
some slots and garlic and some basil
here and fry off cherry tomatoes a few
sun-dried tomatoes so because a really
nice dry tomato sauce
need this together
[Music]
right those needed right that goes in
should double in size
well knock it back and roll it out nice
and thin
right how you doing my man I'm gonna
make the peach in three different
sections already so I'm gonna have one
with me capers and me anchovies and then
we're gonna make it go up control the
one in the middle just for just for the
veggies and then the other seasons but
you're using three seasons yeah yeah
look I'm just spending my options out
Anna what is the most outrageous thing
you've ever done on stage
I didn't do a [ __ ] but he deserved it on
stage yeah I was in Liverpool a guy come
on to review it no way oh you know you
saw at the comedy revue anyway no well
what do you do but I normally cover
pictures what the [ __ ] are you doing
here so I had somebody walk me around as
if I was a dog after who you are all
fours just slip me buns down the way
just but then we have to tell them did
you why you told them it was a prop was
with me technician pretended it wasn't
be on [ __ ] no way it's not even real if
you lose the challenge tonight yeah
don't you [ __ ] on me okay no no
[Music]
[Music]
so this is my dope just gonna roll out
slacking off a little bit and just sort
of get it really nice and pliable and
then roll it nice and thinly I am using
a rolling pin big girl so tomato on
first a nice thin layer of tomato sauce
on there
what kind of mozzarella using the big
ones or the little baby ones I had the
big ones you're copying me again
yeah I just live you know what I mean to
follow you know get clothes in your
style of wood that's nice Ramji parties
girl just sit down something shows up
[ __ ] off and then finish with some
really nice Parma ham right ready yeah
and it goes there you go the three
seasons that you've been tucking the
pistol Oh cuz I [ __ ] school dinners
right right so we've got that we've got
yeah I've got all this all over yeah
just how much no and then they've got a
gorgonzola and then we've got the
seafood yes people have a choice yeah in
this world right good knocked open yeah
and it goes right Johnny they relive
them now yes yeah
ten minutes don't have a pint come back
and you lose no I'm gonna stay and
observe because you're paranoid
no I might need to put a little foil on
if the bit sees my best is not a bit
thicker than yours and have made raw
made with passion
I might have to cover the chops I don't
the tops all but got before the Bursar's
get nice and crispy you mean you might
have to get a takeaway no means I might
have to do a shift on yours right
now it's time for dessert a delicious
hot chocolate souffle may by Ravine de
who last week I chose to be my new Fanny
ravine de well done oh good to see and
you're now gonna make the most amazing
hot chocolate souffle teach the nation
yeah please don't [ __ ] it up thank you
I'm gonna show you how to make the most
indulgent decadent hot chocolate souffle
take 200 mils of milk add 20 grams of
corn flour when it's in a really you're
getting texture you know it's kind of
ready and there you go it's nicely
thickening up chop the chocolate don't
skimp on it
it needs to be about 60 to 70 percent
cocoa content because you need to taste
the chocolate in this add four egg yolks
it's really important that the chocolate
is a little bit cooler otherwise what
you get is this horrible scramble from
the eggs my mother used to say a clear
work surface of a clear mind the
Gordon's got all the dishes to do I hope
he's a good wash wrapper whisk the egg
white slowly add 150 grams of caster
sugar now remember this is what's
breathing the life into your chocolate
mixer you don't want to overwork the
mixture you don't want to get too
enthusiastic more washing for Gordon
really voluptuous you can see it almost
heaving it's really sexy butter around
the king and dust with grated chocolate
[Music]
clean the rim otherwise you'll suply
won't rise so just leave it alone for
six minutes do whatever you want to have
sex read a newspaper I don't know what
you do in your six minutes the perfect
chocolate souffle done lovely lovely
nice nice I'm dying to get in there you
know that good that absolute delicious
fantastic well I've got one thing to say
to you yes buckles out of my kitchen but
only after you've done the washing up
you're telling me to [ __ ] off out my own
kitchen
[Music]
everything that you like season so let
me got boyfriend why
personally fine what about you
if you're going to commit to one person
why don't you guys go on a double date
you and Susan
I saw a Frenchman like JB for that thank
you
he stinks of garlic that's amazing wrist
action you've got there seriously ravine
does that come out you serve the table
go straight to Johnny Vegas yes
be careful Johnny Vegas to see you now
it's time for Jenna Street Porter to
sink her teeth into bernhard Matthews
now as you all know I'm a little bit of
a food snob and this kind of thing isn't
something I'd normally eat frankly I'm
surprised it's still on the shelves
cheery Northup farmer Bernhard Matthews
has had to smile wiped off his face by
three huge food scandals first came
turkey Twizzlers bursting with so much
saturated fats that many schools dropped
them like a stone next came these
horrifying images employees playing
baseball with live turkeys and then just
as you thought it couldn't get any worse
one of his farms was hit by bird flu
during the outbreak it emerged that
Bernhard Matthews that great British
food institution actually uses large
amounts of meat from Hungary but does he
tell you that on the packet like hell
Bernhard Matthews dinosaurs don't know
where it's come from dinosaurs could
have come from outer space Bernhard
Matthew Jackson where they flown in from
burners is in the middle of a massive
rebranding exercise but being clear and
honest about the country of origin is
much more important than flashy logos or
spin so it says turkey breast meat is
often referred to as a superfood because
it's naturally low in fat and
cholesterol but where does it come from
Bernhard of the 21 packets I checked
only two gave the country of origin of
the meat well you might think that burn
is only doing what every other turkey
producer does but you'd be wrong taken
at this lot Sainsbury's fresh British
Turkey this it tells you product of
hungry clearly marked
what's burn its problem o burners
labeling isn't illegal but it is
potentially misleading
I think he's trading on his image as a
Norfolk farmer to make his customers
think all his turkey is English but how
does he do it simple it's all about the
packaging all you have to do is make
your product
look English and not give any
information about where the meat comes
from I'm going to make a turkey pie
using meat from Brazil Poland and
Hungary and see if I can convince people
it's actually English so I've made the
filling for my pie now I'm going to put
the pastry on it and pop it in the oven
here is my packaging turkey pie produced
in England this is perfectly legal now
all I've got to do is see if I can flog
them can I persuade you to taste some of
my turkey pie if I told you that me in
that turkey pie comes from Hungary
Poland and Brazil you know I'm not gonna
catch nothing am i moving misleading
when you look at that box
where are you singing to me and that pie
comes from I would think it comes from
England but if I put this box on the
sand he said meet from Poland Hungary
and Brazil would you buy it
more than I need not what you think it
comes from
I think we consumers have a right to
know where our meat comes from one
person who agrees is David Clarke from
Red Tractor the UK's leading independent
food assurance team if there's a wrecked
tractor on a piece of meat you can be a
hundred percent sure it's British and
carefully reared do you think it's
important that when people buy food they
know exactly where it's come from lately
I mean that's why we have a clear
statement of country of origin within
the logo and therefore the consumer
cannot be confused I think what I'm
gonna do is go to mr. Matthews and ask
him why he won't sign up for you it's
your retractor scheme I think that's a
good idea
he's explaining my concerns asking him
why he doesn't label where his meat
comes from and demanding that he signs
up to the red tractor scheme two weeks
later Here I am in central London I've
been summoned to meet Bernard Matthews
chief executive Bernhard doesn't get out
much these days so he sent his
right-hand man to answer me I have
threatened to serve Bernhard Matthews
with a food ASBO and he'll be my second
one after prints I've got a whole bag
full of packaging here but I'm looking
for where this turkey comes from we've
not realized it's that important in fact
we would welcome all of the origins
meets come on because you'll find that
we still are the vast majority of our
stuff comes in UK hang on a minute on
the 5th of February Burnham Matthew's
company said all our turkeys are British
or turkey eggs come from our hatchery
you know from laying flocks which are
ours in Norfolk yeah so all our turkeys
I know those eggs may go to hungry to be
born but to be reared but the vast
majority of all of our turkeys are in
Norfolk and when you say all that's her
piece of British just that mean that the
ones are in Hungary their mom and dad
some British certainly yeah but they're
living in Hungary yeah so they're
Hungarian sake the best majority of our
products come from the UK and we're
going to very clearly signpost those
products to the British and what
doing on the back because we're going to
take a lead on it and describe when
products of British it'll be very
clearly stated its British we've got
agreement from Red Tractor so we can use
that put the red flag to sign starting
way it will be by the beginning of
September so when it says under burn of
Mackey's that you it's gonna be in here
yeah made from Turkey from our own farms
or from wherever else so that's promise
yep by September the first we'll get
them on ok mr. Dale
hello Janet nice to see my daddy first
of all congratulations yeah I do feel a
real sense movement made Bernard
Matthews mr. beautiful et's words well
done I think they were scared of us
that's a brilliant thing and one of you
to do that to the read practice scheme
so or in your meet that they use your
daddy's Bread on farms in the UK is
gonna have the red tractor good meat
that comes from abroad it's gonna have
the country of origin clearly labeled on
the packet buddy good news so they're
gonna be far more honest they're
fantastic how is he gonna stick to what
I do she promised me that by September
this year they will change their
labeling Congress doesn't do to go and
say no [ __ ] date fries her Pete's
with love bloody well done I think you
scared more of you as opposed to be a
spot scared of a are you God rueful I'm
scared you're too much lipstick next on
the menu will heavyweight Johnny Vegas
knock me out in the recipe challenge and
the choice look at the Claridge's looks
nice B&B Bognor Regis
and will the girls do Lancashire proud I
think we did I hope so you know I really
do
walking back there pod now time to find
out who is the mission style chef and
who is the Michelin Man
are you ready are you saying I'm ready
let's go big boy I'm confident what
you're finishing it with well I've been
a volleyball okay
Oh me and Jovi's whoa I want the fresh
lungs from the bottle look at that hey
looks nice here's my baby coming out
holy mackerel look at that baby
whoop little bit Buzzle on the top I
think your screams Michelin Man screams
family I think your screams cheese shop
you know what they do with it
go on it's late-night phone calls for
the rest of your life
hey Jimmy loves having that pizza Johnny
look at that look at the choice look at
Claridge's looks nice B&B
Bob me Regis right like that sound that
crispy sound just or even it up right
hey it looks nice right listen Cheryl
just a pastor so yeah no no no but
you've got three seasons and four bits
of pizza I know that chest rise that'll
be phenomenal good no I know that you
know that's that's why you weren't money
from it that's right I'll make baking
stone right JB I'll go Ted yes
entertainment right off you go yep the
three seasons by Johnny and the
clarity's pizza boy I mean Jimbo oh yes
- coughs when you put this down
what is exchanged ends in a brown
envelope and I guarantee you something
one
in addition enmity benefit this one yeah
Chris beep hmm we've got some dried
tomatoes really Kate Clapp not too much
cheese either square face yeah cheesier
for sure such attention any other one
hmm okay big boy
no very close very close
it's a three to two it's a three to two
yeah so it's very close telling me that
you're gonna stay in know if you're
trying to tell me what we need to charge
your best it's you Gordon well done [ __ ]
for that three two so close [ __ ]
delicious cheesy but delicious
oh yeah whatever do me a favor well take
your pizza never dark at this wretch
jobs again goodbye I don't show on the
kitchen floor in the way out
no now stand up to the restaurant they
roll there big boy Wow for all you
animal lovers elbow yes yes yes Ryan
[ __ ] you I'm gonna open a pizza here
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll Steve careful now lastly tables and
I'll dust you put them on yes
here we go away okay we've got to 60s
thank you hey JB yes thanks for doing a
job yeah yeah I know France the only one
work [ __ ] in 32 hours a week but
thanks so much for coming
yeah excellent are you trying to no it's
called John Baptist yes good girl thank
you mother we told them that you told us
he was gay
chocolate sooo close perfect absolutely
amazing texture just really nice and
gooey and choppy in the middle
and the mint choc chip ice cream was a
kind of a throwback to my childhood so
like quite sort of retro a little touch
on those side so it was lovely I thought
the dessert was delicious and definitely
worth like that mouth your mouth really
really lovely do the results please now
ladies Justin something we did day 15
yes yeah I hope so you know that I
really do hard we did some of them went
out a little bit lopsided
however the flavor was fantastic but
dessert dessert